aujourd'hui on va se parler d'un bon
plan pour revendre vos objets gagner de
l'argent avec les objets que vous avez
crié pendant le confinement bah oui
forcément pendant confinement on a eu du
temps je sais pas ce que vous avez fait
certaines personnes ont fait du
télétravail
d'autres noms et même si vous avez du
télétravail j'imagine que vous avez eu
quand même pas mal de temps chez vous et
souvent à ce moment là on a pris du
temps pour faire du tri et on retrouve
soit des petites pépites et des petits
objets qu'on allait chez nous qu'on va
pas forcément gardés et on dit pourquoi
pas les vendre se faire un peu voire
beaucoup d'argent avec cette vidéo est
réalisée en partenariat avec ib l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est de vous donner les
bonnes astuces pour vendre vos objets
sur yb et gagnez de l'argent avec ça
vient en complément d'une vidéo je vous
ai faite le jour comment et à quel prix
vendre votre smartphone aujourd'hui on
parle pas de smartphone on parle de tous
les produits que vous voulez ce n'est
pas vraiment de faire un focus sur cette
plate forme pour pouvoir vendre
extrêmement facilement de particulier à
particulier
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement simple
l'idée c'est de prendre un objet que
j'ai retrouvé dans les tiroirs
notamment cet objet là je pense que vous
connaissez c'est une apple world series
2 c'est un modèle que on m'a offert il
ya quelques bonnes années j'ai l'étui
généralement on va regarder comment
faire je pense que vous connaissez ib ib
c'est une des plates formes historiques
de vente en ligne
la question aujourd'hui c'est de voir
comment vous pouvez vendre vos objets
facilement et payer par paypal de façon
sécurisée pour plus une offre est
intéressante en ce moment entre le 20 et
le 25 mai et bien si vous mettez vos
affaires avant de souris mais vous
pouvez gagner des % du montant de
l'avant en bout d'achat pour profiter de
l'offre votre bien doit avoir une valeur
minimale de 5 euros 10 % du prix de
vente sera récupérée en coupons 24
heures maximum après la vente pour un
maximum de 100 euros 2 discount
d'ailleurs ça vous intéresse je vous ai
mis le lien en bas dans la description
je dois vous montrez pas à pas comment
faire pour créer votre compte créé une
fiche produit met en vente et vous allez
voir au final c'est vraiment très simple
la toute première chose c'est bien
évidemment de venir sur le site et vous
allez sur inscrivez vous on part du
principe que vous n'avez pas de compte
alors je ne créez un compte aurélien
adresse email je m'inscris vous cliquez
ensuite sur vendée et gagner des bons
d'achat sur ebay et vous allez pouvoir
commencer à rentrer votre production va
donc regarder comment on fait pour
saisir un produit sur ebay c'est très
simple là vous arrivez sur une page où
on vous demande de créer votre annonce
pour vendre sur ebay extrêmement
facilement donner un titre à votre
annonce ici je vends une apple watch
apple watch series 2 42 mm bracelet
l'icône noir dans bijoux montres et ça
ça me semble pas mal
aucun objet similaire n'a été trouvée
pas de problème je les crée une annonce
la chaîne soit à plusieurs et a ouvert
jamais utilisé non reconditionnés
parfois comme dans nos noms d'occasions
voilà on est sur un produit que très
clairement d'occasion là dessus
saisissez vos coordonnées alors votre
adresse je rentre toutes les
informations de numéros de téléphone
adresses et compagnie le type est un
élément extrêmement important parce que
c'est ce que l'acheteur va voir en
premier il faut bien expliquer de quelle
est votre produit
mettez la marque décrivait le produit
dont on comprenne bien ici c'est apple
watch series 2 il faut que en quelques
mots on arrive vraiment à comprendre ce
que vous vendez l'état et donner envie à
la personne de venir cliquer pour
découvrir la fiche de votre produit
marque apple donc là ça va rentrer tous
les détails on voit bien exactement quel
modèle apple watch iris de taille du
boîtier 42 mm ça l'a reconnu directement
traité les gens et ça c'est vraiment
bien la série est bien coûter on l'a
déjà marqué on va la remettre apple
watch series deux systèmes
d'exploitation compatibles ios
on peut ensuite venir rajouter plus de
caractéristiques ça peut éventuellement
dit rassuré consommateurs on va les voir
ce cas là tu couleurs du bracelet noir
matériaux du bracelet son décès du
silicone matériaux du boîtier ça va être
de l'acier inoxydable me semble t'il
quantité unitaire mais il y en a une
seule système d'exploitation apple watch
pays de fabrication entre cédric en
chine capacité de stockage je veux pas
dire de bêtises mais je crois que c'est
4 gigas si je met plus d'informations je
peux numéro de série ça c'est plutôt
rassurant note dans ce qu'il faut faire
c'est faire une photo vous avez votre
montre vous avez votre boîte utilisé là
c'est rassurant parme et montrer au
consommateur qu'on a ça et que moi ils
achètent un produit qui a été conservée
de bonne qualité mais en plus j'ai même
le petit emballage du bracelet là ce que
je vais faire c'est que je vais l'allumé
pour qu'on va vraiment qu'elle est
fonctionnel ça c'est pareil c'est hyper
important d'y vendre un produit pour
montrer qu'ils marchent aussi nous
enseigne t on sous le feu des photos et
plans jamais montré une méta du produit
qu'il est fonctionnel et bien évidemment
de rassurer pour vous [ __ ] ce que je
vous conseille c'est de prendre en
arrière-plan qu est assez neutre
ça permettra de valoriser vos produits
soit vous avez fait vos photos vous
pouvez les apporter vous pouvez emmener
jusqu'à douze photos à partir de votre
ordinateur
elles sont très intenses l'oder et déjà
je vois que je peux commencer à les
retourner si le format ne correspond pas
ça c'est quand même plutôt bien c'est
extrêmement important que vos photos
soient très bien réussi parce que ça
montre
à dunes à quoi ressemble le produit et 2
c'est extrêmement rassurant pour le
consommateur parce que si on se dit que
la personne a pris soin de faire de
belles photos
c'est qu'elle veut vraiment valoriser un
produit qu'elle a bien entretenu et qui
correspond à la description et qui est
pas un produit de mauvaise qualité
je peux faire un petit drag and drop
pour déplacer les photos montraient que
la photo avec la boîte la boîte du
bracelet et où je tiens la montre pour
moi c'est la photo principale
description facultative fournis par ebay
je peux venir modifier si je le souhaite
je pense que c'est même mieux
puisqu'elle est ce qu'elles soient
fournis par yb est assez simple moi je
veux aller un peu plus loin pour aussi
une fois de plus de rassurer les
consommateurs
la description c'est vraiment un élément
clé vous avait déjà parlé à quelqu'un de
cliquer son beauty qui est intéressant
maintenant on arrive dans ma description
et doit être clair à doit être précise
elle doit être détaillé cherchait pas à
cacher les choses sous le tapis s'il ya
un défaut voulu marquer si vous avez des
micros rayures et des il faut que la
personne puisse me savoir pour qu'elles
ne soient pas déçus
une fois terroir exceptionnel produit je
vends ma montre connectés apple watch
series
2 elle est en bonne état elle fonctionne
parfaitement bien
elle n'a pas de rayures
le bracelet en silicone est également en
bon état
ensuite le prix et c'est là où il faut
pas se tromper quatre sous entre la
valeur qu'ils attribuent à vos biens et
elle coûte réellement aller bien
évidemment jeté un coup d'oeil sur ebay
les outils sont là ils se permettrent à
trouver facilement la valeur exacte
alors on a foi sans pouvait faire des
enchères là il fait une enchère avec un
prix de départ de 57 euros et on voit
qu'au final le prix de vente moyen
s'élève à 104 euros
ou alors pourrait venir faire le choix
d'avoir un achat immédiat
personnellement je préfère avoir un
achat immédiat même si au final mon prix
plus bas
je me dis que si elle part aux enchères
à 64 euros ça peut être un petit peu
moins bon 104 euros trouvent ça a quand
même un peu cher je pense que sur la
valeur moyenne de ce que j'ai vu sur iv
ce que je veut en tirer
85 euros ça me semble est plutôt correct
livraison je veux envoyer l'objet
sélectionné un service de livraison
alors lettre ça me paraît être un petit
peu petit j'ai plutôt fait dans le colis
personnellement j'aime faire un
colissimo ça me semble plutôt bien je
paye et je le rajoute directement dans
les frais de livraison vous pouvez
économiser jusqu'à 40 % sur les frais de
livraison en utilisant la plateforme
d'expédition et ensuite je peux choisir
les moyens de paiement pour être réglés
soit paypal via mon adresse via mon
compte soit un virement bancaire
personnellement paypal ça me convient
plutôt bien je suis payé directement
c'est simple c'est pratique et sécurisée
ça me va très bien ensuite je vais
rentrer les paramètres d'expédition ou
est ce que je veux envoyer mon code
postal la ville donc vous voyez pour
mettre en vente un objet sur ebay c'est
extrêmement simple vente de particulier
à particulier il vous suffit de remplir
votre titre votre description bien
choisir votre prix votre photo le moyens
d'expéditions et c'est vraiment simple
et sécurisé ces pratiques
d'ailleurs dit moi vous est ce que vous
avez fait le tri chez vous pendant
confinement est ce que vous avez trouvé
les petites perles avant de série b est
ce que vous avez déjà revendu des objets
sur ebay où est ce que vous comptez
faire marquer moi tout ça bien
évidemment en bas quant à nous on se
retrouve extrêmement rapidement pour
ôter de sifflet plein de plans plein
d'astuces donc ça c'est cool
nous on reste non beaucoup d'amour très
très vite quelqu'un
[Musique]